so if people are joining this livestream
this is continuation of a complex design
discussion about our EF Sparkle and
generally graph-based
rep ontological and other
representations in Multan language so
should I run this code here or is not
hopeless that's hopeless I guess okay oh
it's good to know so various things are
going to work what others not too late
this okay all right what should I see
here so first a little overview of what
we are going to discuss at all so there
are basically three or four categories
of things to discuss one the first thing
is just an eye an identifier which is an
eye our I did a nationalized resource
and identify the second thing is rdf the
resource description framework and the
third is sparkle which is a query and
update language for rdf and there two
things to consider first there's an
in-memory representation of RDF data and
you get this already of data by for
instance importing an RDF file or by
writing it manually and then writing a
sparkle query against it as you can see
there's a symbolic spoken query the
second option is you have a sparkle
endpoint and you send it either a
sparkle string or a symbolic
representation of a sparkle query and
get a result okay so let's talk about
our use case of this right what's what's
the plan here is the plan here to use
this as a way to query our serf or what
the plan is
to query Sparkle endpoints and
potentially back entities points the
self might be one but probably
realistically an earlier are outside
Sparky endpoints and custom entity
stores okay but I'm not a big believer
in the outside Sparkle endpoints I mean
all three of them that exist in the
world after all these years I mean but
but so you're saying for our custom
entity stores that will be a place where
we could use this technology to do
querying is that right yes but now our
entity stores right now are stored how
in memory Association or nested
Association okay so this is a way of
having a a custom entity store that is
not being stored as a relational
database stored in some other way is
that right
yes so there are these two types of
pecans that we are considering in the
moment when it's relational databases
and the others craft databases mm-hmm
and this is the Guelph database case yes
and for any given entity store by
looking at the structure we could
potentially decide whether it should
reasonably stored offline as a as a
graph database or as a relational
database is that correct yes okay okay
so now in terms of the query and we
talked about how this relates to you
know growth patterns and things like
this right yes so a lot of this
discussion here yes they're after the
RDF discussion there's a discussion of
sparkle in detail with all the possible
patterns that you can write
my gosh
first are the query forms that decide
what kind of thing is coming back from
the query at all for instance the
sparkle select returns a list of
associations Sparkle construct returns a
graph and here are the patterns that are
supported by Sparkle okay but how did
this relate to how does this relate to
our pattern language so various of these
of sparkle patterns having
correspondence in the Wolfram language
for instance the union pattern and
reuses alternatives okay I think this is
a very complicated set up what's the
first place we're gonna get sort of
clear payoff from this what's a minimal
example where we
obviously does something useful that's a
very long pause yeah okay so one one
dead
I personally imagine would be if we take
the archive steel beams and one day put
them in together with mathematical
structures in a large entity store and
then say finds me the minimum way how I
go from the four Coliseum to the capital
connector
that would be a Jenny nontrivial big use
of it yep I mean okay that's clearly not
an everyday know you know okay so this
project seems to have gotten a lot more
complicated since I last saw it we
discussed it Tony would implement the
classical spark to the functions to have
a representation of them in the language
mm-hmm that's what you did
okay so of outside's you know Sparkle
based endpoints what are the ones that
you care the most about
I feel spooky data so far okay and is it
interesting what you can get from that I
see a lot of contributors the last time
I checked I saw something like 40,000
active contributors miss active defined
PI's on so many contributions in the
last months and if there's a fair amount
of data okay so fine I mean we've
already got a lot of this ourselves in
the way so it's not completely clear yes
um you know but but so again is there a
Wolfram Alpha query that would be I mean
is this something like you know get you
know all capital cities that are in you
know on rivers in countries that have
whatever whatever whatever whatever I
mean is that yes the goal is that you
can write such 20 to her grace against
existing entities okay
and and what would that query look like
I mean so right now we have just the
entity of blah and then we have this
sort of second argument which is you
know population arrow between blah blah
blah and blah blah blah something like
that so it would reuse exactly the
certain tax that we are going to discuss
you
Sparkle query syntax applied to an
entity type or list of entity types and
these entity types implicitly represent
an RDF graph and then in the worst case
this graph has to be materialized before
evaluating the query but in most useful
cases there will be a shortcut to doing
that okay another question in terms of
the flow of this project what fraction
of it have you done I mean are you at
the early stages middle close to the end
what's the story
so Sparkle query and sparkle update both
pass all w3c tests that means they are
mostly standards compliant expose things
that are not covered by the tests maybe
okay so you're telling me that apart
from the design which we are not yet
sure about that implementation aliy what
you have is working yes nice good ok so
now we have to look at the design all
right yes implementation it's not
optimized in every case in there still
bugs and some converters but yeah ok I
mean that to be expected you be in every
case perfect because it does arbitrarily
complicated cough metrics which are
known to be non-trivial um sorry I'm
sorry what'd you just say Michael sorry
it's not you expected that every case is
optimized because it you can formulate a
better complicated cough matchings which
we know is a bit complicated right ok so
let's take a look the I thought that was
one of those some hey I read this first
of all maybe I've been reading too many
obituaries here um ok the um ok so what
is the
creature that's turtle totalus one of
the format's to serialize an RDF graph
so if I take that aw DF graph and I want
to simply display it as a regular you
know one of our standard graphs
displayed as a as a network is there a
way to do that
I'm not directly okay so so there are
some ways to transform or represent an
RDF graph is a graph but this is not
directly possible seems like it would be
a nice thing to have I mean for a
complicated well it's not going to be
terribly useful for small months it may
be useful yeah
right um maybe this up maybe a little
bit going out of the normally cough
things and do a little bit more coloring
so that they're easier to understand by
time so if we say graph of this or
something like that maybe it gives that
not sure
setting or should it preserved meaning I
think it's mostly for display I agree I
would actually say it's you apply it to
the string golf okay fine because yeah I
think that's better yeah that's fine
okay okay so now that we have seen the
introduction we could maybe go to RDF a
little bit down we start from the small
parts building up to the bigger ones
well let me look at this example here
sorry okay so oh my gosh where did you
define color so it's a variable and
currently be your symbols for variables
but without scoped there's
scoping mechanisms so another option
that you would have is having something
like a sparkle variable I don't
understand what these are doing what
you're doing is you're coming out with
these are pattern variables effectively
and is that right and you're coming out
with the the form with every possible
form for these four fruit color and
shape is that correct yes
so actually what this more is it's more
like a table or something is no no a
different way to put it funky how do you
make if you have an association okay and
you're going to make a the analog of a
table for an association okay so if I
say Association do we have an
association table no we don't how do you
do that how do you make if you want to
have something where the two columns are
the keys and values or not remember
table yes that's that's the kind of
thing I mean I would do list at normal
associations edit it will matter no no
no but but what I'm asking this this
construct here okay where you are
generating essentially this outer
product right if I'm not mistaken what
you're doing is this thing here is
asking so I could have completed
everything here I could have a specific
fruit etc etc etc no I'm very confused
so so that was so technically this is a
join between the triple patterns that
you see they're lovely but what I want
to know is what you're saying is what
comes out here is the data extracted
from this database where for every
entity in the database for which
you're giving me the fruit the color the
shape is that right for every entity in
the database yes
another way to look at it you're finding
all the sub graphs and then you're
returning all the variable bindings that
make this graph pattern a sub graph off
the whole graph okay but now I'm
completely confused here because there's
this this IRI here yes these are short
forms because this this is normally a
longer IRI and it's using these prefixes
to shorten them it is one of the
mechanisms to shorten okay so this
triple here it is basically
that the color of this fluid is color no
I understand that so but that's that's
an edge in the graph basically that
thing that goes is from a of fruit node
through a I am that color node to a
certain color right
yes so what this is doing is it's saying
in the graph and find all instances
there's like a cases it's more cases
than a select isn't it yes there could
be a different function graph cases that
we had mentioned before
patterns right but the as far as its
concerned the knowledge that see this is
returning something this is returning a
pattern binding we don't have a good
mechanism for that if I say what if I've
got some cases for example and what
you're doing here is you're asking for
these specific binding so let's say I
say f of X blank comma Y blank and then
that matches a particular thing you're
asking for X arrow whatever Y are or
whatever we don't have any mechanism for
that right now
yes we discussed something like a
function called matches that returns
these matches or bindings yes which will
be analogous to what you have here yes
okay
season that
I mean the thing I'm a little confused
by okay is that in a cases type setting
what will you be doing here is we'll be
saying I mean if it was a graft cases
for example let's imagine that we had
grant cases okay and that now these
these named edges we discussed that
before also we discussed having the
possibility of having on a graph edge
having some representation of a naming
on that edge am i right yes and with
some nice notation okay
so assume we had that and assume that
let's imagine that I call this graph
edge which is not a good name but but
then then what would happen is we'd say
graph edge of foo X blank so then this
what this would be is would say graph
cases of my graph comma graph edge blah
blah blah or in general
this would be a subgraph here I mean
this in fact could just be a graph
that happens to have a single edge and
I'm going to just for the sake of
argument actually it's not a completely
stupid notation that is that a stupid
notation
inside a graph to do something like that
it would be the fluid forms I don't know
named rule or something or label it
looks nice
and it would format as X and then a long
arrow with a few on top of it they would
look for you feel that no one problem is
that you will internally have double
rule because you have a rule of rule and
it's not clear what is this man yes yes
I agree okay so we need some other way
of entering this what's another way of
entering this so I think we had
discussed previously some kind of thing
where what what can we do here we could
do
I think we can't just fight it out okay
fine all right so then then let's say
that this is okay so that the written
out form of this would be graph edge do
we have anybody from do we have Charles
or anybody from the graph theory no we
didn't think it would get so much into
the golf course
okay in any case this would be what we
would have something like that and what
would come out of that naturally in a
cases type way would be a collection of
graph edges right with the with the ex
isn't instantiated actually it would be
a collection of graphs
yeah but but clearly here if we wanted
X&Y and star yes we could always do this
yes no no no yes but I think you Stephen
and Tony you meant something it the
aggression was is the SAP part of a
cough a cough or is the sub part of a
coughing edge this is well I'd be
prepared to be flexible and I think we
have to be flexible on that single at
general case the graph pattern has
multiple edges so and so the result
would be a list of edges wrapped in
grass fine fine so it's a graph but then
alternatively just like standard cases
if the right hand side is given some
other thing to do with that binding
otherwise it will be a sub graph that
happens to have instantiations of x and
y but right yeah otherwise it would be
mapped like this yeah I mean personally
I'm quite keen on seeing a you know a
piece of functionality like this and I
don't know what the in terms of that
property mechanism in graphs there's
another way you know there might be
another way to represent this okay so I
think I get more or less what's
happening here and I don't really agree
with from what I'm understanding you
know this is very sparkled pandari so to
speak so so the idea is and we also
discussed with charles that we have a
sparkle of focused functionality in some
context currently graph store that is
much easier to implement in a very
general graph cases functionality and
then they'd already be valuable on its
own okay um okay maybe we should see if
Charles can join us here um okay but
you're suggesting that there's something
which sort of pander to the whole
Sparkle world that might or might not be
exposed at at in in the full system
context and so on yes yeah I think so
too at the beginning fine but I think
there will be useful to try to implement
stuff like this even if it's only simple
cases of it for right now I mean this is
going to be I mean this is essentially
just a binding for Sparkle here and I
don't fully understand orchids of course
done in the returning to the salt yes
but I also well and also this Iife aynd
the mechanism here really weird with
these unbound variables and so on really
weird I mean I would find it more
sensible if there was an outer wrapper
associated with that sparkle query that
enumerated because I don't even know
what order to put these in what why is
it coming out in this order as opposed
to color shaped fruit
so in this case it returns all the
bindings for rebel variables that appear
in a pattern and later you can project
variables that means we turn a subset of
okay fine I'm I'm asking you even just
the ordering why is it not shaped color
fruit Charles will be here shortly
so the orders not defined that means it
can be any well I know but maybe it
should be defined I mean it's an
association so it doesn't really matter
much but what I'm suggesting is that you
wrap this thing in something which
essentially declares those variables you
can have another argument yeah that's
what I'm suggesting is that if indeed
sparkle query generally has these
unbound pieces what you should do is to
map is to say what is the name that
you're going to use you know you should
be able to call those unbound pieces x
y&z okay or if this one agrees with that
one X and X and so on or even X blank
possibly but then you need to be able to
have some mapping which I'm now really
confused by because I think it makes
what is this analogous to so in other
words what's that process here okay hi
Charles okay um okay
so what is this way we're talking about
graph pattern matching um do you
understand what I'm asking so these
variables here which are going to be
sort of presented as keys in this
association or nested list of
associations I'm trying to understand
what's an analogous case where you are
see I claim that they're two different
concepts one is the name of the key
associated with that position and the
other is simply the presence of a dummy
object in that position
I mean you would return something so
we're having a nonfat on the object
there's nice otherwise if it's a bet on
you don't know what to return no I agree
but well look yes
but I claim what you need is sort of a
template for what you're returning
somewhere look what you basically need
is something I mean something like okay
let me let me suggest something crazy
okay this may be crazy
hold on actually it's not totally crazy
yes
okay so here's an idea okay I don't know
what the default is but let's imagine
that the how many of these there are but
but um okay let's say it
fruit graph and then there's this thing
but instead of this I'll actually let me
write this out in a more explicit way so
why blank blah blah blah and that's of F
graph
I'm so confused I mean I I'm what I was
thinking was something like this and
that that's more like sparkle cases than
it is like sparkles select but I think
you want sparkle select of F cough cough
okay fine that's not what you had before
but that's okay but then this is quite
right there's no I see I see then then
this goes inside right well then we must
only deal with the optional one
a shape included otherwise kippot
where we don't have a very good I mean
well nothing they did well really what
it is it's a nothing like play if the
shape is nothing then that Association
doesn't have a shape in it right
but um yeah I mean but right now
Association doesn't doesn't prune
nothing's perhaps it should okay so that
case prunes but what you're telling me
is this case does not prune although it
absolutely could prune
can we um and convinced whether it
should prune yeah okay because you might
want to use this as a table for first
look up and then you really want this
nothing
but why would you want there to be
nothing there I mean because like I use
a long association as a fast lookup
table for something yeah I understand
that but but but okay well that's a
separate discussion because then C would
disappear then I cannot metric a and C
anymore just been missing instead in
which case in the case way you want it
to evaporate yeah when it's kind of
doesn't exist inquiry well wasn't formed
because you said it's optional I feel
like that's a disability I mean if I say
here D I'll get missing right the issue
is whether there's something that causes
an association to condense and you know
okay but let's let's put that on the
aisle the agenda if somebody can take
that to them so we have a project
manager here no I can okay okay so so I
would suggest something like this it may
not this may not be exactly right but I
think that cleans up the semantics of
these otherwise completely crazy hanging
you know unscoped creatures here that
are just flying around who once ruled
allegiance to the rule right quite
possibly I'm not sure I wasn't thinking
about that
so there are some features of sparkle
that are not compatible with these
parent objects and that might become
clear later when we review some of
having these unscoped hanging variables
isn't going to work so maybe this helped
in some way so the other idea that I had
and I had actually implemented it's very
beginning was having a sparkle variable
this the argument the name of that
variable it's a little bit related to
quantity variable but it
a long time typing such patterns yes
well and also also it ends up with
something where it's coming out I mean
you know the role of the variables as a
thing to omit is really weird
that is I don't know of another example
where a variable appearing within
something causes it to enumerate on the
outside that variable did you get what
I'm saying I mean actually we have in
relational databases an analogue of that
because we have new properties that we
are introducing and we also have
variables that define the database
columns for the top level and so what we
do we introduce this entity function
with those scoping variables which we
then compile to the underlying database
primitives
okay so entity function what is
explained to me the relationship of
entity function to this it's just an
analogous construct which does kind of
the same scoping thing that you are
looking for does the entity function
produce these kinds of you know multi
keyed results or no no no that's the
problem here that there are I mean
entity function remind me how entity
function works so basically it's a
property like construct that allows you
to it usually has one variable and then
you use that variable to compute things
like for instance you know if it's an X
then you can write something like X of
price times X of I don't know copies
sold or something like that times X of
copies sold and this is the second
argument and the first will be just X
just like in a function so and then it's
a scoping construct that basically tells
you that you introduce a new property
with the value given this product and I
understand so there's some kind of dual
thing to this go ahead yes we could
introduce another argument
declares the variables before we use
them yeah but so what you're still
having exposed variables coming out here
that's the problem yes that's not going
to work as such but but but they're
going in and but that's like a
polynomial what do you mean by that take
your input has already the food variable
so it's natural that it comes out
yeah I understand but but what I don't
you why this is a problem but they are
not coming out directly
what are coming out or leaves the string
names and the variables are presumably
can be any dummy thing you can change at
your at will what's not string names
these are not string names these are the
actual variables here oh yes so yeah
this is pretty loopy I mean let's keep
going for a second we're gonna run out
of time here but but let's just keep
going for a minute so what were you
gonna point me to you were gonna point
me to the audio stuff so yes here first
the Aria I that should be pretty obvious
it's a generalization of URL and UI and
then the RDF here's some example
vocabulary that the examples we'll use
later then then we just start by the
basics of RDF which is an RDF triple
with which you can make a statement
subject predicate object then you
complain strings like e^x all right this
is the vocabulary I introduced you for
instead of writing the long I our eyes
which are supposed to be globally unique
identifiers yes you under to use some
shortcuts you okay for example for us
with
respect our surf those could be entity
objects is that right yes so there's an
analogy everything that is already
f-type is more or less considered an
entity because at this analogy
not completely korsunov also properties
are entities because they are of type
property which is not the case in ours
since we could lift our bodies in
something like entities by the way I
think so but this is just convention and
it's not standardized how to interpret
these things so the next generalization
from an RDF graph is an RDF data set hmm
which contains a default graph and some
named crafts and then you later can
write queries that by default go against
the default graph but you can address
these named graphs and do queries over
both or why why is it set up this way
why don't just have whatever those leaf
graphs or have some structure that
represents that why you packaging
multiple leaf graphs together so that is
just one way to model let's say a data
set that contains current data and
historical data so by default if you ask
population of Spain you get the current
data and you can ask for the historical
data of Spain like the others later when
we get to sparkle I show some examples
of that if you think that's a nice
construction because like if we provided
a data repository entity stores or coffe
stores with prepackaged with a nice
amount of information but the user is a
little bit more that the user can easily
add a little bit more I'm little
because this isn't it doesn't look very
computable here you've got these
specific they're become clear later when
I show the examples but let's first
discuss just RDF and later the querying
of these rings because this is the most
general which people currently don't use
so much this order of datasets but this
is the most general form the next are
the order of literals which are
basically string and the data type that
defines what the string means and here
is an example you know okay the next
thing our RDF blank notes I don't
understand how this represents this this
is this is some kind of a TD or
something for that year so there's a
standard that defines what the data tag
identified by this fire I means and in
this standard you can read how to
interpret the string at the beginning
and yes your sparkline point or whatever
can process that further or not then
blank notes so in some cases you don't
need to identify a note you just need to
say it's there and it's related to other
things like if you say the age of the
universe is such-and-such you have a
composite value in general of the value
and the unit and you can use that by
using blank notes for instance just an
example okay the next thing is an
language tag string you know I mean
this is a lot of stuff that is you know
for which we have other constructs so
for the language that I included only
the things for which we don't have an
analog or at least I'm not aware of any
yeah we don't have this we don't have
that tagged string so we are for
instance reused same date object you can
write a data object in a sparkle query
and that will work because yeah there
I'm using the analogous operation so
then there are some operations on RDF
graphs like finding isomorphisms or
isomorphic graphs but maybe we can skip
that in a first reading merging RDF
graphs by standardizing apart blank
notes yeah
RDF collection RDF entity store we shall
discuss that only later once we discuss
database begins and then there's some
converters we can maybe skip the two
it's just some formats in which 30s is
stored and now we start with the sparkle
theory oh boy
the rapper Spock look very that
encapsulates me a query sparkly execute
that deals with communicating with a
sparkling point
different query forms like
like a select that returns a list of
associations which is the thing I didn't
like okay but it's basically doing as
close to the standard as possible you
know whatever analogous thing there is
in the Wolfram language Sparkle ask
checks whether as pattern or pattern
exists in the graph Sparkle construct
returns a new graph based on a pattern
and the template for making this new
graph okay so this is just really
Sparkle translated a sparkle binding for
our language because none of this stuff
like calling it asked to have it what's
essentially a cue function this kind of
is kind of officer in or from language
world that would probably be graph
member q yeah and Spargo select would be
graph cases
yes they trade all of this was proposed
to go into cos store baked a context
right but I still want to know how we're
actually gonna use this I mean so you
know can you give me a ranking so wiki
data is one Sparkle end point that it's
out there in the world I mean there was
an enthusiasm for these things like a
decade ago and then they kind of just
evaporated to my knowledge there was
some medical ones but I don't think I
haven't heard anything about them in
years well I haven't used any headers so
far well possibly better find out what
else there is um and but I mean the
argument for this what are some examples
in our own use of entity stores so you
gave one example
Michael involving comb and stuff I think
it's really only pays off if the entity
store has a certain complexity did did
it make sense to must have many or not
many at least a few different types that
you couldn't go form under the nozzle
did not otherwise you're basically back
to a rectangular entity property I
understand I understand I understand
which is but I mean in our semantic
relations framework you know we do have
a certain amount of graphism there yes
and right now the implementation that we
have of the serf so is it the case that
we could imagine reimplemented the serf
using these kinds of constructs would
that be sensible would that be nuts
would that make it more efficient with
that make it less efficient what do you
know what do you think I don't know sir
felon of tool and today
no trip to answer this I think we should
determine the answer because this could
either be I mean it could go either way
it could be more efficient less
efficient you know I don't know I mean
but that would be a case where I mean if
we were to start from our existing
entity structures what would it look
like I mean if we were to try to define
a syntax for I mean right now if I say
you know something like entity you know
I mean this this I consider to be
somewhat impoverished syntax okay you
know something like that right the fact
that I have to do enter in lists it's
kind of funky here boy
this list seems to change every time I
look at it and it's crazy as a city in
that list that I've never heard of
okay in any case okay so my question is
in this world okay if I wanted to say
cities whose population is greater than
one tenth of the population of the
country that they're in
okay so that's right there yep cities
whose population is greater than 1/10
times population of the country they're
in so Leonid in terms of entity function
this is an entity function kind of play
is it not yeah so you start with at
least in terms of their relational like
I could I could tell you how you would
do this in the relational world so you
would start with the entities cities and
then you say entity yeah you will do
something like entity select sorry you
started you start with entity select and
we select where first argument is entity
class cities or entity city and 30 yeah
or entity class city comma all then you
write any D function which is going to
be a predicate then you say something
like small capital city just a variable
you could call it anything and then you
say City Open bracket string population
right close bracket larger than one or
one tenth off and then you do something
like entity property path because in the
relational world you need to actually go
to the table country which is related to
the table city so in in our world
without you know the super structure of
relational ism it would be what country
that city and yeah that thing it would
be population yeah I guess this will
also work for us too
as a shortcut yeah and that's about it
okay
that doesn't seem bad to me by the way
where am i storing all this stuff to
somebody no okay probably an ILD
stole you notes Tony do you remember
where this is what the grass story is
there's a thing called sparkle i'll so
this is SW notes three and a spa Cola
okay so that's that now tell me the
sparkle analog of that I just sent it in
the chat Wow very efficient thank you
okay take a look at this okay hold on
hey I see this really bothers me here
okay so what you're fundamentally saying
is that which we kind of already knew is
that a sparkle thing is a very
it's basically entity it's all about
pure relations between things
it's not about for example numerical
values or anything like that it's about
this has that relation to that is that a
fair statement yes okay so and the point
is that as you go collecting this has
that relation to that you can see which
nodes have the appropriate relation
structure then you can pull out those
nodes and do computations on them as
you're doing here or the whole pause
yeah I mean I kind of think okay but
still want to be fair this is a very
simple query and in really complicated
cases the requires which are very hard
to formulate in the SQL world which are
possible to form the way it in spark
world okay give me an example
well I can't over the top of my head
I've seen those but basically you know
relational databases are they have a
rigid schema and there are things which
are not pretty well matched to that
schema okay so like genealogical stuff
who no actually genealogical is just
fine because you can relate from a table
to itself it's rather that when you have
I'm asking things like somebody who has
an uncle mm-hmm does that working in the
in the relational world somebody who has
an uncle yes why not you just need to
first refer to the to the father and
mother and then check if any of those
house for brother I see okay okay so
then what is an example of something
that is hard to represent that way I
mean these things that let's say
bibliographic data so somebody has a
co-author
who has a citation that has a dis that
has a coauthor is that what the
representor is that also easy to
represent no that's also easy I was more
thinking about things which are maybe
yeah I'll have to think about it
something which is not explicitly
aligning well with this existing schema
of the database okay so Tony can you
give examples of this no because yeah I
don't know which one is actually harder
but sparker queries can be translated to
relational queries because the First's
ok so let's look at our own world of
stuff here
so what we have in our own world of
stuff is we've got you know so we've got
really two representations here we've
got entity you know blood property you
know goes to potentially some other
entity it could be a value but it could
be some other entity I mean that's how
we that's the that's the you know that's
our current way of doing it
evaluates to that
now what you're saying is that you've
got these you know RDF triples
entity property
entity is that correct yes okay so
for us right now this is more like that
audial the presence of that audio triple
is more like something like this right
yes yep um so and in general what we're
trying to do which we're not doing here
is a pattern match play on these things
we could have something which says find
me okay so this is pattern version so
we've got we've got both a pattern
version and a function version I claim
okay let's try to understand each of
them so this is the this select with a
function yeah so this will be a select
blah blah blah with an entity function I
claim that is one way I think the
depends a little bit what you want like
in this example very good away you or a
single entity I think that's the right
thing but if you're interested in the
past what connects about Einstein to to
gold you're more interest maybe in the
past then a value I understand
actually a very good example it's
definitely something which would be
pretty hard to expression let's just
understand that because the reason it's
hard to express you are okay so first
point is things it's hard to express
relational way so one thing would be an
arbitrary length path from A to B right
because we'll sell yeah I'll think sells
- yeah right okay now if you have a
finite length path you can name every
sub every waypoint right and then you
can easily unravel them if you if your
path is simply going from city to
country to population to this to that to
the other no not really because it might
be
even population is one of the things you
don't want to name yes she may not be
interested necessarily what are the
intermediates of the path you couldn't
principle name them and throw away the
names yeah but in the relational world
that would be that would decide on which
way you're kind of walking over the
relations so it's not even clear how
would do you how you would formulate a
query where you don't specify through
which tables you're going to go well I'm
sorry that seems like an implementation
issue I mean this thing here right yes
you're jumping from table to table here
but you can surely you handle that in
the compilation phase for that query it
means it means it's you know it's
population but if you're interested in
any property that will do yeah so you
don't know which ones you're requesting
so I see you're saying if any of those
properties if exactly is whatever okay
so things are sought to express so
another one is a a wild card property eg
you know if their properties like anyone
related in any way to Enron or something
that type of thing whether it's the
accountant the executive whatever else
is that right yep okay we unfortunately
arrive time here um we we need to
continue this before we all forget how
it works I think we're making progress
here next time need to make sure Charles
and Leonid are both present because I
mean we've got really two sides to this
story do we need somebody representing
the serf like Jeremy Michaelson if we
are thinking this direction yes we have
let's let's do that okay okay and I
think what we want to do here I mean my
feeling is that the you know okay so
local
let's box in what we're talking about
here I mean having something which is
merely a binding for Sparkle ISM seems
fine although I don't know how much you
know and I think there will be some
people who have you know who for
whatever reason of Miss spent years or
whatever have large Sparkle end point
stuff and they will be can be very happy
might be useful to talk to sales or
partnerships to find out if they
actually know people have large have
asked about large Sparkle plays so to
speak I think there have been those over
the years so so we can actually find out
I know did Ellen has spoken with a club
with people don't know ok fine but let's
figure out who they are
let's try to get a list of who who
actually cares about essentially the raw
native Sparkle ISM fair then let's make
an assessment of how this can dovetail
with our entity function world the surf
world and the graph world okay and I
fully expect that what you know that
we'll be able to map some of those
things into what Tony has done some
things will work efficiently some things
will not work efficiently there but
that's you know being able to unify the
entity function stuff with this graph
stuff would be interesting and the use
case the particular case that I can see
doing that for is the surf which is like
just one very complicated entity store I
mean is it the case so Michael another
thing we should come up with is a list
of those things maybe things we're doing
internally for which it will be useful
to use a graph database so we are
already using graph database that can be
well represented here yep okay and let's
continue that next time and for those
who have been watching this live stream
will hope to see you for another episode
of the excitement's of
what of triple stores and okay see y'all
soon